aside from being consistently awesome as
a wrestler the iron cheek is also one of
the sport's more tragic figures
so much so that it's almost a miracle
he's still alive from personal tragedy
to bad decisions to flat out pure pain
the iron cheek has lived a rough life
the iron sheik birth name hossein khasro
ali vaziri
was born in iran in 1942. he grew up
poor with much of his family's meager
income
coming from his father's business
growing pistachios like many young
iranians of his generation
the iron sheik's hero growing up was
olympic wrestler delam reza takti
a four-time olympian and three-time
medalist including a gold medal at the
1956 summer games in melbourne he
inspired the sheik to take up wrestling
sheik recalled to badoon magazine that
at age 15
i wanted to show my parents i could be
big just like him
in 1968 takti was found dead in a hotel
room
his death was officially ruled a suicide
but many believe that he was killed by
the iranian government
for his work against the existing regime
the death served as a wake-up call for
the sheikh who later recalled i knew i
had to leave if iran was not good for
takti it was not good for me
iron sheik will always be largely
remembered for his legendary bout with
hulk hogan sheik taking the leg drop
dropping the title and kicking off
hulkamania is one of the most important
moments in wrestling history perhaps
even the most important moment
since then sheik has had a running
public feud with hogan
she claims he has a reason for the
hatred and as one of wrestling's most
persistent rumors after a brief run in
the wwf
hogan spent the first few years of the
80s working with the american wrestling
association
out of minnesota under owner vern ghania
hogan returned to the wwf
in 1983 with vince mcmahon planning to
make hogan the new face of his company
with the iron chic bout
the long-standing rumor is that a bitter
garnier offered cheek 100
000 to break hogan's leg and take the
wwf world heavyweight championship back
to minnesota and offer chic turn down
after informing mcmahon it's a story
sheik has told for decades and hogan
himself claimed the story of the bride
was true on the steve austin show
little did i know vernon contacted the
sheik and said i'll give you a hundred
grand if you break hogan's leg
you know longtime wrestling personality
bruce pritchard confirmed on his own
podcast something to wrestle that he had
also heard the story at the time
directly from the sheik
playing a heel in an era when cavefabe
was very much alive didn't just mean
beating up heroes it meant making the
audience believe you were a terrible
person
wrestlers and managers from the 70s and
80s often tell stories of death threats
with many taking pride in them it meant
they were doing their job
manager jim cornett framed many of the
death threats he received
showing them off in an episode of the
dark side of the ring the iron cheek was
no different
and the identification of him as a sort
of foreign enemy
added an extra level of danger to his
character for american audiences
it's been reported that security had to
sneak him out of the arena in ambulances
because fans would try to attack him if
he showed up in his own car
he was often grabbed by fans mid-match
and reportedly stabbed on several
occasions
it was a dangerous enough situation that
he forbade his family from traveling
with him
in 1987 hacksaw jim duggan and the iron
sheik were pulled over on the jersey
turnpike or headed to a show
the cops found a small amount of weed on
duggan and an eight ball of cocaine in
the sheik's bag
this arrest caused two problems one
professionally and one personally
it was also a harbinger of things to
come professionally it hurt both sheik
and duggan because the two were feuding
at the time
and sharing a car while cafe was still a
critical part of the business
was bad all around why would two mortal
enemies carpal much less party together
the event infuriated vince mcmahon
declaring in a locker room meeting
that the two would never work for him
again in typical wrestling fashion
both were eventually rehired but not
before taking a big hit to their careers
personally it's her because the news
eventually made its way down to his home
in atlanta
it wasn't just a small news piece either
it was picked up by the ap
and also appeared on the front page of
the atlanta journal constitution
sheik's wife carol pulled their
daughters out of school for three days
the event was also a preview of the drug
problems that would haunt him in the
decades to come
drawing the lowest point of the iron
sheik's life in the early to mid-2000s
he was unable to stay out of trouble
this in and of itself isn't all that
surprising what made it tough was that
his celebrity and natural charisma
made it hard for him to face the
consequences necessary for change
as an example in 2005 his family forced
him into rehab saying he was a danger to
himself and others
while in rehab an employee likely a fan
snuck an eight ball of cocaine in for
the wrestler
tanya one of the sheik's daughters
explained her frustrations from this era
to bleach a report
saying people were taken by his
celebrity and they wanted him to like
them
when the cops would arrest him that
drive him home instead of bringing him
to jail
every time we tried to help him he'd
charm these fans and then push back
against us
the most tragic moment of the iron
sheik's life happened outside of the
wrestling ring
he faced the worst pain a parent can
imagine the death of his daughter
marissa vasiri amir 27 year old was
strangled to death by her boyfriend
charles warren reynolds on may 2nd 2003.
the sheik was already vulnerable having
recently come out of knee surgery
and this pushed him over the edge the
murder sent him into a spiral
often called the lowest point in his
life his wife carol told yahoo sports
how much to death hurt him
he was this big strong guy that everyone
had relied on for so long
and in this situation there was nothing
he could do to save her it devastated
him that he couldn't have been there and
tried to save her
as tragic as the death of marissa was
her depressed and furious iron sheik
almost made it worse he had a plan he
was going to kill charles warren
reynolds during his court hearing this
wasn't just the grim fantasies of a
grieving father
cheek hit a razor blade in his cheek and
sat in the gallery the plan was to wait
for an opportune moment to barrel past
cigars
spit out the razor and cut reynolds
throat his wife carol got wind of the
plan
and his family colluded to make sure the
wrestler couldn't pull it off
they boxed him in near a wall and all
sat around him forcing the immobile
sheik to have less of a chance to spring
during this time his daughter tanya
reportedly whispered
quote you can't kill him because i'll
put you in prison i lost my sister and i
don't want to lose my father
this was enough to keep she calm during
the hearing and he pledged to quit drugs
as a tribute to his deceased daughter
the iron sheep grew up avoiding drugs
and alcohol consistent with the shiite
islam beliefs he grew up with but that
changed after entering the wrestling
industry
he claimed to bleach a report that he
first started using drugs after fellow
wrestler
jimmy superfly snucker offered him a
joint the industry's loose attitude
toward partying saw sheik abuse just
about every substance imaginable
it's easy to get caught up in all the
legendary stories of what he did during
the heights of his addictions
it's fun to think about him
belly-to-belly suplexing fellow
wrestlers through hotel beds or stashing
his cocaine in someone else's clothing
or trying to get across the canadian
border but all of this overlooks the
fact that he was a very sick man who
kept getting fired from his job
and putting himself and others in danger
his drug addiction
only got worse after he stopped
wrestling there were regular reports of
him acting aggressive
and violent towards others even at
conventions his home life was a mess
with his family both
worrying for his life and living in fear
he managed to quit several times but
often came back
his hardest relapse came after his
daughter's death when he started calling
his drugs medicine
in 2007 carol couldn't handle her
husband's addictions and erratic
behavior anymore and when the sheik was
out of town she moved out she later
recalled to bleach a report i could no
longer beg him to quit we had lost our
daughter
we were all sad and depressed but enough
was enough the separation lasted for two
years and ended only after sheik agreed
to sever ties with the man who'd
accompany him to drug purchases
according to sheik's daughter tanya this
man had become her father's best friend
suffering this friendship was tough but
it was also possibly the best thing that
could have happened to him
he was forced to take sobriety seriously
and moved back in with his wife
while sheika said he still drinks beer
he claims for being cocaine free since
2009. he told bleacher report in 2013
it was pretty hard but i don't miss it
anymore she had beef with toronto mayor
rob
ford after the mayor's crack scandal in
november 2013
sheik showed up at toronto city hall and
challenged ford to an arm wrestling
match
do you want to beat the mayor at an arm
wrestle absolutely that's why i'm here
when asked for his feelings toward ford
the sheik told the ottawa sun
the man eats a cheeseburger and smokes
crack what kind of role model is that
for the city
i just want to know if he is a real man
or not in april 2014 with the toronto
mayoral race gearing up
the iron sheik was in the city promoting
his documentary he arranged a meeting at
a local eatery with olivia chao
a politician with the left-wing new
democratic party and at that time
the leading candidate to win the race at
the meeting sheik proclaimed
god bless her and i want all the people
in toronto to vote for olivia chao
to become the mayor of toronto not long
after the meeting the right-wing
apparatus in canada
came gunning for chow the national post
ran a column criticizing the meeting and
endorsement using gain sheik's long
history of inflammatory statements
in character or otherwise as a bludgeon
against her reputation
xiao apologized for taking the meeting
the producers of the chic documentary
released a statement about the incident
saying we're not amused by an
agenda-driven newspaper's transparent
attempt to use the movie as a political
football to embarrass a mayoral
candidate the paper does not editorially
support
chao ended up finishing third though
it's a stretch to say the sheik had
anything to do with that
there's a reason you should never call
wrestling fake around actual wrestlers
especially old-timers the damage to
their body was real
many deal with back pain heart issues
and all sorts of assorted health issues
the iron cheek is no different
he spent years suffering from knee and
ankle injuries that bother him even in
peaceful moments
the sheik had surgery on both his knees
in the mid-2000s
a surgery that both he and his wife say
didn't work his wife says that his bones
are out of alignment and walking is
painful
some of the proceeds from his 2014 the
chic documentary
were used to pay for his double knee and
ankle surgery it's hard to find a
picture of the iron cheek from the past
decade or so but he isn't walking with a
cane or getting carted in a wheelchair
when yahoo sports went to interview him
he initially told them to come back
later because he was in too much pain to
answer questions
when asked during a reddit ama if he'd
ever come back for a guest appearance in
wwe
the answer was flatly no due to the
damage that his body had already endured
if you or someone you know is struggling
with addiction please call the substance
abuse and mental health administration's
24 7 national helpline
at 1-800-660 that's 1-800-662-4357